hello
everyone and welcome to a webinar my
name
is geraldine hamilton i am the president
and chief scientific officer at emulate
and one of the founders
it is my great pleasure today to
introduce
our speaker lorna she's our executive vp
for european scientific liaison and in
her current role as
emulate lorna leads the applied
biosciences group
to support services and new application
development
and she also works very closely to
provide scientific support to our
commercial activities
lorna comes to us with over 20 years of
experience in the pharmaceutical
industry spanning from pharmacology to
drug safety
and she has been a champion for the
organs and chips field since the early
days
of the technology prior to joining
emulate lorna established and led the
center of excellence
for the technology within astrazeneca's
r d unit
and lorna and her team were actually one
of our earliest collaborators in the
development of the liver chip
well back when our team was at harvard
she also has extensive experience with
multiple other chip technologies from
different academic groups and different
companies in the field
earlier in her career she served as a
therapeutic area lead toxicologist for
respiratory and
inflammation at astra seneca and today
lorna will be providing an introduction
to a platform
and then she'll be discussing data with
us that highlights how our alveolus long
chip
and all airway longship can be used for
applications such as the study of viral
infection
and development of medical
countermeasures and therapeutics
and with that i am delighted to
introduce young passy over to laura
thank you geraldine for the kind
introduction
and i will just move us on and get us
started it's my
pleasure to present to you the inaugural
lecture or webinar i should say for
or emulate and the webinar today is
focusing on our lung chip
and we will be looking at how the lung
chip can accelerate the study
of viral infection and therapeutics
so on entering this new decade life
across
our planet has changed beyond all
imagination
such changes are demanding that
scientists urgently adapt
their ways of working to accelerate the
mechanistic understanding
of disease pathogenesis now
is the time to fast-track therapies that
not only treat symptoms
but also modify the course of underlying
disease
now nature is an amazing engineer
it's created many complex structures
that enable the exquisite functionality
leading to life as we know it
but modelling this complex biology is
extremely difficult
in cell-based systems that's where our
organ chips come in
by becoming cell architects we have
created a home away from home
for cells through a blend of design
engineering and biology this tiny chip
can recreate the smallest functional
unit of an organ enabling us to more
easily
and accurately study the inner workings
of biology
that underlie health and disease
so let me introduce you to our chip
this is a short video to help orientate
you
around your chip so if we take a cross
section through the chip
you can see the tall top channel here in
blue
and a smaller vascular channel on the
bottom
these two channels are completely
separate and they're separated by this
membrane
a porous flexible membrane with pores of
around seven
microns in diameter can see
cells on either side of this membrane
usually epithelial cells in the top
channel
and endothelial cells in the bottom
channel
and with the unique feature of our
vacuum pump we can stretch
where organs require it we can flow
media
independently through the two channels
and if we need to
again for organs such as the lung we can
replace the media in the upper channel
with air
so why organs on chips
well organs on chips really help us
model
complex human physiology and disease
the combination of the epithelial
endothelial cells create a nice
tissue tissue interface
the physical micro environment that the
chips generate through the dynamic flow
and mechanical forces provide
critical stimuli to cells that guide
their behavior
and their functionality we can add
circulating immune cells to the chips to
see
cytokine and chemical release which is
very reminiscent of clinical phenotypes
and finally we can test therapeutics in
our system
from an efficacy a safety or a
pharmacokinetic perspective
by adding drugs to either side of the
channel
i'm going to show you some work that
started the
the lung check field off and this is
original work that was done
in 2010 published in in science
and what we're looking at here is the
fundamental aspects of
inflammation in the immune system in the
lung chip
so if we flow labeled neutrophils
through the bottom channel through the
vascular channel as you can see in the
video that i've just started
they flow very very nicely however
upon seeing an inflammatory stimuli
we up regulate adhesion molecules such
as icam1
and this causes the neutrophils to start
to stick
to the under surface of the vascular
channel
now not only do they start to stick they
become curious
they're motivated to move through the
release of chemokines
and we observe this in this following
video where we've tracked one neutrophil
and we can see weaving and wobbling
around following the chemical gradients
and eventually diabetes and through the
membrane to the upper channel
and if we also then look at our final
video where we've now labels
our neutrophils in red the neutrophils
in this case have moved
from the vascular channel to the
epithelial channel in order to engulf
the bacteria
that was responsible for setting up the
inflammatory stimuli
this is how our bodies function and it's
a unique insight
into the biology
so why why study viral infection
and and what models do we have available
to us
well we have many models available to us
from cultured cell lines
precision cut lung slices lung organized
through
to our organ chips now we know
that each of each system each model
isn't perfect
no model is perfect however there are
significant disadvantages for culture
cell lines
precision cut lung slices and indeed
long organoids
that actually prevent it from completely
modeling the complex biology
and this is where the organ chips come
in i'm going to show you data
in our presentation that will hopefully
illustrate
why we can actually start to recreate
and
physical and clinical phenotypes and
responses
at clinically relevant drug exposures
but we also have animal models available
to us
and many many people use animal models
particularly to study respiratory viral
infections
but it's becoming increasingly clear
that there's many species differences
when it comes to viral susceptibility
and actually when we look at the
translation of inflammatory responses in
animals to humans
they don't always correlate
so we as a consequence we see a very
limited recapitulation of the clinical
phenotype
this help this means people often
migrate towards
non-human primates for instance and that
leads to expensive and complex husbandry
requirements
so our thesis is that organ chips can
actually help
provide an ideal model system to study
respiratory viral infection
through the use of human cells on these
chips
so i'm going to start by introducing the
airway lung chip
m2a so first of all i'd like to show you
a video which nicely illustrates the
characteristic
pseudostratified epithelium so that's
the elongated epithelial cells with the
densely
packed nuclei and this is particularly
characteristic
of the human airway that you would see
in
inside the body below you can see the
endothelial cells forming a nice tight
monolayer
and if we go and look at those cells in
a bit more detail and start to try and
characterize them
what we can look for are the main cells
that we would expect to see
following around about 14 days of
differentiation under an air liquid
interface
so starting on the left hand side the
first image that you can see
is of club cells and here we're using a
marker
cc16 which is a secreted protein from
club cells and they are stained in green
the next image along is the ciliated
cells and here we're staying for a major
protein
in the ciliata cells beta tubulin and
that is stained in red
and finally when we look for goblet
cells
here we've used the stain for mach 5 ac
in green which is one of the major
museums produced by the goblet cells
so overall our chip has the correct
and phenotype of cells and that
are all fully differentiated when
cultured across a near liquid interface
and to show you this in a little bit
more detail this is a beautiful scanning
electron micrograph of the cilia on
our chip the ciliated cells have been
stained on blue
the nonciliated cells are the brown
cells which are
going to be a mixture of goblet cells
and club cells
and to show you this in a bit more
detail to show that not only do they
look nice
they actually do function so the video
that you can see on the left hand side
is the cilia beating nicely
and the video on the right hand side is
a blob of mucus
that has been secreted from the goblet
cells and is actually moving as a
consequence of these cilia beating
and one final demonstration of the
functionality here of these ciliated
cells if we were to place
fluorescent particles into the airway
channel of our chip
we would observe this characteristic
upwards movement which is where the
cilia
are trying to sweep these particles away
and
if it were in the body away and upwards
and they're
ultimately out of the body
so i hope they've shown you that the
airb lung chip has
human relevant biology and here's some
further facts and figures
that we can demonstrate that that
principle
but what i really want to draw your
attention to
are the two figures at the bottom of
each of the circles
on the left hand side it's the human
lung and on the right hand side it's the
human lung chip
so i've demonstrated that we have the
key cell types that are present
but actually what's also important is
the ratio of those cells
so in the human lung for instance around
about 30
of the cells are ciliated cells we see
in our lung chip
20 to 30 percent of the cells are
ciliated
and equally if we look for goblet cells
the human lung
10 to 15 whereas in the human lung check
we're somewhere in the region of 10 to
20
so we believe we've really recreated the
lung
airway so let me now show
you how our airway lung check responds
to human rhinovirus infection
so human mind virus we use here with
type 16 so i may refer to it going
forward as hrv
and on the graph on the left hand side
of the slide
what you're looking at is the viral
titer on the y-axis against the time
post-infection on the x-axis so you can
see within the first 24 hours there's a
nice
increase in the viral tighter in the
chip indicating that the virus is able
to replicate
inside the chip it remains steady for a
further 24 hours and then gradually
declines over the course of the
experiment now if we were to look at the
impact of the viral infection
on the epithelial cells under a bright
field microscope
you have you see the images on the left
on the right hand side of our slide
the first image is of a non-infected
cell where if you look very closely you
can see
the nice epithelial cell structure
but on the right hand side what you'll
see is a chip that has had
hrv 24 hours post inoculation
and what you can now see is you can see
that the epithelial cells are very
rounded
and that's indicative of very extensive
epithelial damage
so we decided to have a closer look at
what was happening with the hrv
infection
so it's been reported in the literature
that the ciliated cell is actually a key
target
for human rhinovirus so here we have our
ciliated cells on the image on the left
hand side
this time beta tubulin is stained in
green
and what we're looking for here is
double-stranded
viral rna which indicates that the virus
is actually replicating
we've stained for that in red so these
ciliated cells are clearly packed full
of this double-stranded
rna now if we were to also take chips
that had been exposed to human
rhinovirus
and used a tunnel stain what we can
actually see
is a large number of green cells and in
in the middle image and that's
indicative of
apoptosis and indeed it's been reported
that the
hrv infection causes a sloughing and
apoptosis of ciliated cells so not only
can we see this
um morphologically within the lung chip
we can actually measure the functional
consequence of that
and that's the graph on the right hand
side of the slide
here you're looking at cilia frequency
and
in the open bar that's the control chips
or the non-infected chips
and you can see in the gray bar around
about 50
reduction in cilia beat frequency
because of the hrv
infection turning our attention then to
the goblet cells we also know that hrv
infection causes a hyperplasia within
the goblet cells
and that's to increase the amount of
mucus that the cells produce as another
line of defense
to this viral infection so looking at
the image on the left hand side
the non-infected cells you can see and
some red staining for the goblet cells
which is exactly in line with what we
would expect
but 24 hours after hrv infection we can
actually see a large
increase in the number of goblet cells
representing this hyperplasia that's
been reported
and the graph on the right hand side it
shows you the quantification
of the change from the non-infected chip
to the infected chip in a 24-hour period
now clinically we know that rhinovirus
infection will cause the release of
men cytokines both that are
pro-inflammatory as well as chemokines
to
also bring in another cell type into the
airway
so here what we're looking at is cxcl10
and it's one of the members of the
interferon family and again
it's clinically being demonstrated that
the interferon response is a
very early and necessary response to
fighting the rhinovirus infection so you
can see that the chips infected with hrv
in grey show an increased amount of
cxcl10
the two the next two graphs the first
one mip one alpha
and the one on the far right mcp1 also
show
increased levels of secretion following
viral infection
and these two chemokines are known to
bring in the alveolar macrophages
again is another line of defense to
fight the infection
so let's look at the airway lung chip
now with the different virus and this
time we're looking influenza virus
this work was actually done with our
partners and collaborators at the vesa
institute in harvard
and what we're looking at here is um
again some nice immunofluorescent
images of the epithelium but
additionally this time the endothelium
so starting on the left hand side the
upper panel is the control
and here we're staining in red for a
tight junctional protein called so one
and what we know about influenza
infection is that it likes to break down
so one and break down these tight
junctions so if you look at the image
below which our chips have been exposed
to the virus
you will see that there's an absence of
so one staining
similarly to the hrv infection influenza
also affects the ciliated cells so the
next image
that you can see are cilia stained in
yellow
in the control chip but in the presence
of virus again
a real loss of ciliated cells
now this time the virus was a gfp
labelled virus so we were able to detect
it in green
in the upper panel you can see no virus
in the lower panel
you can see that the virus has actually
infected
cells now additionally
we're looking at the endothelium so the
underside the lower channel of our chip
and for the control here we've stained
for ve catarin again to show that we
have nice tight junctions in the
endothelium
but the presence of the virus which was
only added to the epithelial layer
has actually made its way through to
damage the
endothelial layer and this we believe is
responsible for the vascular leakage
that's often reported in influenza
infection
so what happens when you start to try to
therapeutically
intervene in the airway when the airway
lung chip when we're infecting with
virus
so in this experiment ozil tamivir acid
osv
was used which is the active ingredient
of tamiflu which many of you will have
heard of before
now tamiflu is used clinically and is
known to be particularly effective
if it's given within the first 48 hours
of
infection or first 48 hours of a patient
reporting symptoms
so here the data we're looking at is all
48 hours post-infection
and starting on the left-hand side what
we're looking at is the
relative tighter so the amount of virus
that's in the chip
and we've normalized it to the control
and you can see that with one micro
molar of osv we can bring the the viral
replication
right down by about 90 so very
very significant impact now
remember we said that the virus actually
and breaks down the the tight junction
and when that happens
the the barrier that's there becomes
leaky and we can measure that using
the apparent permeability so
in the presence of virus which you see
designated on the x-axis as a plus
there is an increase in apparent
permeability indicating a leaky barrier
however when virus and osb are added
together
that tight barrier is actually um
reformed and we can see this
morphologically by the images on the
right hand side
and these are actually some of my
favorite images
so we're looking first of all at the
control where zoo one is stained in red
really nice tight junctions secondly
the virus taking away those tight
junctions
and then finally the restoration of
those tight junctions with the addition
of the ozotamivir acid so
this explains some of the therapeutic
benefit that muscle tamavir
acid will actually generate
but we also know that um chemokines
and cytokines are an important response
to viral infection
and so here we've looked at chemokines
and cytokines that are known to be
part of the clinical phenotype and again
48 hours post-exposure
the chips that received virus plus
osv show very much reduced
cytokine and chemokine release again
contributing to the therapeutic action
of this drug
now let's turn our attention to a
slightly different drug this time it's
nephamostat
now in the thermostat it's actually a
clinically used
anticoagulant and it's very effective as
an anticoagulant because it's a
particularly
potent serine protease inhibitor and
what we know about
viruses is they like to gain entry into
the cell and they rely
on serine proteases to help them do so
so here when we give 10 micromolar of
nathan stat
again at and the data sorry here we're
looking at is 48 hours post viral
inoculation
first of all we can look at the barrier
integrity
so again here using the apparent
permeability
empty chips clearly would be very leaky
so we see
quite a high apparent permeability
in the presence of the virus but when
cells are are there too
we equally see a very high permeability
but interestingly treatment with nafasta
over a 48-hour period
reduces that barrier leakiness restoring
that barrier integrity and again
morphologically we can see this with the
restoration of the tight junctions
by the reappearance of the zo1 protein
in the nephamistat treated
chips and similarly to the picture for
osama or some of your acid and we're
looking here
at the chemokines and the cytokines that
are produced
following viral infection and we can see
very clear evidence that the inhibition
of this host
seeding proteases um is leading to a
reduction
in inflammatory cytokine and chemokine
release
so part of the therapeutic
benefit that this drug will give to
influenza patients is clearly around the
serine protease inhibition and reducing
the amount of viral entry
into the cell
now one of the reasons i love organ
chips so much
is that we can actually do combination
drug testing
in the organ chips as well and it's very
clear for viruses such as the sars cov2
virus that
to be successful in therapeutic
treatment
we will more than likely need more than
one drug so combination drug testing
will be
what we need to do to see therapeutic
benefit
so in this graph we're looking at two
different scenarios
first of all at the minus 24 hour time
point we're looking at a prophylactic
treatment so that means that in this
occasion
drug was given to the chips before the
virus was given
now this is a very artificial situation
because
i don't know of anybody who goes to the
doctor 24 hours
ahead of time and say i think i'm going
to have a virus tomorrow please can i
have antiviral
drugs that doesn't happen but it's
actually a really good test
just to make sure in a complex cell
system for instance that
you can add virus as we have done to the
control chips and fight
you can measure the viral tighter but
then when you add the drugs either
independently
or together prior to the virus of course
you can see
that there's very much a reduction in
the viral titer
but what's more realistic is what we
call a therapeutic
exposure and that's when drug is given
um at the same time as the virus
and onset and if we follow that course
of time
from zero hours through to 96 hours
we can look at how each drug works
itself
or in combination so the light gray bars
are then the thermostat
by itself and the dark gray bar is the
osv by itself and you can see that both
drugs will reduce the viral titer out to
about 48 hours
and this is definitely in line with what
was being reported clinically
but what's really interesting is that if
you give both of the drugs together
in the black bars we can actually keep
that viral titre down
out to 96 hours so in other words we've
extended the therapeutic window
for a further 48 hours
now i'm going to change gears and talk
about the alveolus lung chip
you'll recall at the beginning of the
presentation i highlighted that
organ chips are actually representing a
fundamental
um functional unit within the lung
and the alveolus is is an independent
functional unit of the lung
as opposed to the airway it has its own
unique structure
micro environment and of course
functionality
so we've adapted our protocols and used
the adapted protocols with alveolar
cells to build an alveolus lung chip
so in this occasion we've taken human
primary alveolar epithelial cells we've
seeded them
again on the upper channel of our chip
and
looking at the image on the top right
hand side you can see beautiful
zone so one staining in green showing
very nice tight
junction monolayer formation which is
very typical
of the human alveolar epithelium
we've used microvascular lung
endothelial cells on the bottom channel
and again looking at the images on the
right hand side
you can see we've stained for vectoring
in pink
showing again very nice intact tight
junctions
and just to give ourselves confidence
that we're looking at the right
endothelial cells
we've equally stained for enviroband
factor in green
so far all of this data has been
unpublished
now those of you who are working with
alveolar cells will know
that actually it's incredibly difficult
to keep
type 2 pneumocyte in a type 2
phenotype once it's removed from the
body because it rapidly wants to
differentiate into a type 1
and what's very exciting about the
images that you're looking at on the
screen now
is that the unique alveolar micro
environment that we've created
has enabled us to keep type 2 cells
through at this point in in the in the
slide out to day seven
under an air liquid interface and how do
we know that
well in the middle image you can see
that we stand in green for pro
surfactant c
which is one of the putative markers for
type 2 cells
because their function of course well
one of their functions is to secrete
surfactants
another putative type 2 marker is ht2
280 and so the image on the right hand
side you can see we've stained for those
cells
in green so we can see type 2 cells
but the image on the right hand side
we're also stating for polar planing
it's a type 1 pneumocyte marker so you
can see
that in our trips day 7 under an air
liquid interface
we actually have the correct micro
environment that will support both type
1
and type 2 pneumocytes
and if we look at the gene expression
and what we're looking at here on the
left hand side
are surfactant c and b to represent the
type
ii pneumocytes and on the right hand
side aquaporin 5 and podoplanin
for type 1 pneumocytes and we've
compared the gene expression in chips
to static 2d cultures so you can see
quite clearly that surfactant is present
in both the chips through to actually
day 15
and um we similarly see our type 1
markers also present in the chip out to
day 15.
now the alveolus and
it went in the process of breathing it
it curls and uncurls
and and that's partly how the lung
becomes a very efficient gas exchange
organ
so the image that the movie i beg your
pardon that you're looking at on the
left hand side if you look very closely
you'll actually see these cells moving
and this is due to the unique ability of
our system to provide a mechanical
stretch
to the cells now we were concerned that
when we add
the mechanical stretch or indeed that we
start to add the air liquid interface
that this may affect the tightness of
our epithelial barrier
so the graph on the right hand side
shows again the apparent permeability
that we're measuring first of all very
high in an empty chip where there's no
cells
but you can see that we maintain a very
tight barrier
in this graph out to nine days either
under the liquid liquid interface
or the air liquid interface and with
mechanical stretching throughout
so this mechanical stretching doesn't
actually disrupt that monolayer
integrity
it's very important to show that we have
the physiology there
now i'm going to show you how we've used
our alveolus chip
this time for risk assessment and this
was done in collaboration with one of
our farmer partners
and what what they asked us to do was
they asked us to try and recreate
an in-vivo response that they had seen
in their animal studies
with one of their drugs so in this
particular experiment
pbmcs were added to the alveolar channel
that had been pre-incubated with drug
and what they learned from their animal
study was that the drug target
was present on the alveolar cells on the
epithelial cells
and they wondered if we could also see a
similar
effect that they saw in the animals so
we added the pbmcs
with that had been incubated with drug
into the alveolar channel they did
indeed engage with their drug target
present on the epithelial cells this
caused the cells to become the pbmcs to
become activated
and start to release cytokines the
cytokine
release continued to ultimately the
point where you saw
apoptosis of the cells and ultimately
damage was reported
so in any good drug study we started off
firstly by looking for
the drug the presence of the drug target
in our cells
so at day three under a liquid liquid
interface
day six and day eight under an air
liquid interface
we stand for the drug target in pink and
you can see
that it is present throughout the
experiment
so what we did was we added drug on day
8 and followed
the course of events for further 48
hours
and what we saw um was immune cell
toxicity
48 hours after drug exposure so if you
look at the
top chant at the top images these are
bright field images
and the bottom images and the ones with
the blue cells are live imaging
you can see then for the vehicle cells
if you look very closely you can see
that
beautiful alveolar epithelium
and then if you look at the live cell
imaging below you can't see any pbmcs
there
nor can you see any apoptotic cells
which would be in pink
now if we gave the the cells some pbmcs
that had a negative control in it so not
the drug of interest
the brightfield image immediately you
can see the pbmcs as the lighter
brighter
circular cells in the bright fields
image
and down below the lighter blue cells
with the occasional
pink apoptotic cell
but really interestingly when we gave
the pbmc's
been pre-incubated with the drug you can
clearly see
that the epithelium has started to
become damaged
and that we can see we can back up with
the live cell imaging with the increase
in the number of pink cells
indicating a larger number of apoptotic
cells
now in the animal model this was
accompanied by
a cytokine response so using clinically
relevant concentrations of drug
we also looked to see whether we could
see in the chip
the cytokine profile that was observed
in the animal models
and these graphs show you across four
different
um cytokines that there was a
concentration and time
dependent response of the drug
to the cytokine release
this shows us that the um the chip
can recreate the immune cell interaction
and cytokine response and this
contributes to the overall risk
assessment
that the company wanted to perform
so i'm going to finish the presentation
with a few slides on infectious disease
applications
and focus particularly on the topic of
the moment
coveted 19.
so organ chips are perfectly positioned
to help in research and understanding of
covert 19.
so i'm going to show you some data in a
minute around ace2
and serine protease tmpr tmpr
ss2 expression in our lung chip but we
also know
that these two key and proteins
are also present in our intestine chip
and in our kidney chip
and these two proteins are extremely
important
for the attachment and entry
of the virus into the cell
our partners at in harvard have actually
shown
with us sars cov2 pseudovirus that they
can actually infect
our lung chips with the virus so clearly
they can attach and the virus can enter
the cell
and i've just taken you through some
data albeit with different viruses hrv16
and influenza virus that these viruses
will replicate inside the cells
ultimately be released from the cells
and cause damage
such as barrier integrity and cytokine
release
so the lung chips are perfectly
positioned
to look at potential therapeutic
strategies against
viral attachment viral entry viral
replication and subsequent
inflammatory cytokine storms that occur
when the cells burst open
looking then at the airway lung chip and
and the expression of proteins that we
know are important for the sars
cove to infection the graph on the left
hand side is looking at serine protease
expression
and it's comparing the increase in
messenger rna expression
in fully differentiated chips compared
to in black
mdck cells which are cells cultured
in in a dish in two dimensions
or to the gray which is the
cells on the chip that are
undifferentiated
so we can see that four key serum
proteases
are all increased in differentiated
chips
compared to the cell line or
undifferentiated chips
making this a good system for studying
serine protease expression
and the effects and functionality that
that brings
on the right hand side we've stained for
angiotensin converting enzyme receptor 2
or a2 you can see that undifferentiated
chips
there is an absence of ace ace2
expression
because there's no green staining and we
stained
ace2 in green whereas differentiated
cells on the right hand image
show that the ace2 is clearly present
once the cells
have differentiated on the chip
so this gives us key information
that proves our lung chip will be a good
for
studying viral attachment and cell entry
now although this virus is very new the
amount of research that's going on is
actually quite phenomenal
and if you follow some of the literature
what you'll also begin to understand
is that this virus has different
pathogenesis
in different organs and at emulate we
have
intestine judem and colon chips
and we've already demonstrated that we
know that the ac2
is actually present within those chips
so our chips would also help
in the discovery and understanding of
how this virus
is actually operating also clinically
many very severe patients come into the
into the hospital and they present with
altered liver function
so we have a beautiful liver chip that
will also help us understand
how the virus impacts the liver
and finally it's become clear in recent
weeks
that ace2 is also present on endothelial
cells
and if you recall it's one of the unique
features of our organ chip
that they are they have the endothelial
cell present
and at emulate we've spent some time
developing a blood vessel chip
to allow us to look at thrombosis and
it's become
clear that some patients with covid19
actually have an increase in the number
of thrombolytic
events and we believe that our blood
vessel chip would be ideally suited
to help us study this too
so in summary organs and chips for
covert 19 research
we can think of it in three different
ways first of all we could consider the
chip
and its value in basic research looking
at pathogenesis
in multiple organs hypothesis testing
from computational models and artificial
intelligence
and finally and very importantly we
believe that they can stay for the long
term
in terms of doing retrospective analysis
to help prepare for future
outbreak responses we can also use them
in drug discovery and development
where we can test the efficacy and
safety of potential therapeutic
candidates
and accelerate the repurposing of drugs
that's currently underway and finally we
also believe they have a clinical
application
through the discovery and validation of
biomarkers
as well as being able to explore
potential variations in patient
populations and so with that
i'd like to close this webinar and i'm
very happy to take questions
which i hope you've all been doing
through the chat function as i've been
talking
thank you very much for your attention
thank you lorna as lauren just mentioned
we're now going to use the rest of our
time for the hour for a live q a session
we received a lot of great questions
during the presentation so we're going
to start with those
but as a reminder if you have any
questions just click that question mark
icon on the right hand side of your
screen submit your question
and we'll add it to the queue our first
question
is about uh the cell types used in these
studies
so what epithelial and endothelial cells
are used
in the alveolus and the airway lung
chips
yep that's a really good question so
all of the data that i've shown you
today have all been from
human cells so
we procure human cells from the
airway and from for the alveolus as well
as the endothelial cells from commercial
suppliers
and so that from the airway perspective
we use um airy cells as well as and they
will have some basal cells which we
start to mature through factors in the
media and the alveolar cells as to say
are
directly isolated and contain type 1 and
type
2 cells
and to follow up on that question are
the endothelial cells that are used lung
specific
yes they are we and we always do that
when we
build our organ chips we always use
endothelial cells
from the organ of interest because there
are actually
a number of differences in endothelial
cells from different organs so
and to have the right organ chip and
have them let's say have an alveolus
chip it wouldn't make sense to put
endothelial cells from the liver in
there for instance so
yeah the endothelial cells are also
pulmonary in nature
our next question is about the length of
cell culture how long can the cells on
the chip
be in culture this is important for
repeated exposure
of test articles uh and can this be used
for testing cova-19 infection
assuming they have ace2 receptors so two
parts of that question
yep absolutely so let me start off first
of all with the alveolus chip
and we would deem our chips to be mature
from eight days and we are confident
that we have good viability
out to 12 to 14 days so
maybe a period of four to six days for
the alveolus trip
for the airway chip it takes us around
two to three weeks
to mature the cells and but from that
point onwards we can
have at least a further two to three
weeks of good viability of the cells
and to the question then on whether that
would allow
treatment for m therapeutics absolutely
it of course it really depends upon the
the end point
and the duration of action that the
individual would like to study but i
believe
there should be sufficient um window
there in both
of the two chips to assess the
therapeutic effects
so the second part of the question
around ace2
expression i showed some data that we
can
find the ace2 in the airway of
the airway chip the cells that that are
there once they're fully differentiated
so
out to any time from about two to three
weeks
after seeding onto the chip and at this
moment in time
we haven't actually yet stained our
alveolar cells
for ace2 receptors however this is work
that we will shortly be doing at emulate
our next question uh is about imaging
so how do we label the epithelial and
endothelial cells chlorophyll
for fluorescence microscopy is it
possible to label them while the cells
are still
inside of the organ chip and then
examine them under a confocal
or does this require taking the cells
out of the chip
yeah that's that's a really good
question and one one which i really like
to answer
and so yes you can do it in either way
is the short
answer so most of the imaging that you
saw with the exception of a few images
in the alveolus chip
was done as a what i would define as a
terminal endpoint
so that's where at the end of the
experiment we fix the cells
in the chip and we apply our
immunofluorescent antibodies and then
look at the cells under our confocal
microscopy technique
but you can apply m cell trackers to
look at live cell
imaging and that's what we did within
the alveolus chip
and and we we know that we can do this
and
fairly well we can take the chip and off
the fluidic platform for about 30
minutes the flow will still remain and
so perfectly good time window to
actually do some live cell imaging
i'm less of a fan of life cell imaging
if i'm being very honest because
i think there can be some challenges
with um photo
and so it does require perhaps further
optimization than a terminal
immunofluorescent endpoint would require
we have another question on endpoint
measurement so can you recover
cells after their culture in the lung
chips and
is there enough biological material to
perform techniques
such as pcr wb or elisa
yes absolutely so um
in terms of elisa most of our allies and
measurements are done from the effluent
of of the chips and
but there yes we can take the cells at
the end of an
experiment we can gently tryptonize the
cells off the chip
and there is sufficient material there
to do
um pcr and and we can actually also do
western blotting if that were
appropriate as well so yes
a follow-up question on uh imaging
techniques
i think you started to mention this
before but what microscope setup do you
need in order to do lifestyle imaging
yep so we we just use a standard um
laboratory microscope that has the
correct um
lenses and and bulbs that enable us to
do it so nothing
um out of the ordinary nothing different
to what would be in a standard
laboratory
our next question is is there potential
to include the longship
in studies for vaccine development
um yes and so i i believe there is
i haven't seen yet any data um
on any check actually whether that be
ours or
any other chip on the marketplace at the
moment but
um it would require a little bit of
further development
because clearly one of the rules for um
vaccinations and
and proving efficacy of vaccinations is
being able to see the appropriate immune
response so
we would more than likely have to um
adapt our current protocols to allow
further inclusion
of immune cells in the chip and once we
were confident we had that
then yes we could use them for vaccine
evaluation
our next question uh is about using
chips as a translational model
so at emulate do you get requests from
clients for
animal organ chips as sort of a halfway
house before going into human
models and to support confidence in chip
models based on their ability to
recapitulate animal data
that is more familiar to end users
love that question fake very close to my
heart
absolutely and so actually um
astrazeneca
janssen and emulate published a paper
that made the cover of science and
translational medicine
um in november last year and that's
exactly what we did it was
and this was in the liver trip we
created a rat
a dog and a human version and the idea
behind doing that was
exactly to address the question of
translation so that paper nicely
outlines how
we were able to recapitulate responses
that had been seen in vivo in rats
or in dogs in the liver chip and
moreover
show in one of the cases that had had we
actually
not stopped a molecule because of a
response in a rat
and and taking it forward to the clinic
the data from the chip would indicate
that actually the human
had um no no response so
perhaps we didn't have been as sensitive
to the response that the rat was
so that really opens the question about
how many drugs don't make their way
through because
um they show positives in animals so i'm
a massive fan
of being able to do this across more of
our models
and i would love to have the opportunity
to do that in the lung models
the intestine models and indeed and any
of our other models that we we currently
have
so very much welcome people coming
forward and
talking to me more about that because i
do think it will help
build confidence that and if we can
continually reproduce
effects from animal models in our chips
and show differential responsiveness to
to humans
it really will open up the opportunity
to discover
new new therapeutics
our next question is uh directed at
geraldine
so can you expand more on the types of
endpoints that you can measure on the
chip
can i measure what i would normally
measure in conventional cell
cultures for animal models
yes indeed i think that's a great
question
i like that question because i think
it's something a lot of people when they
first
see the system wonder about and i think
basically the answer is
anything you can measure in conventional
cell culture
or an animal system you can measure in
the chip from
rna gene expression levels
transcriptomic analysis
anything that's eluded in the chip in
supernatant that flows out of the chips
cytokines uh in delivery for example we
measure
um ldh or other secreted enzymes
and so i think the answer is if you can
measure it in your regular
normal studies in conventional culture
and in animal studies
for the most part you can measure in the
chip now some
end points require optimization of the
assays but that's usually more related
to finding the right
kit and not so much to do with the chip
thank you geraldine our next question
is on comparison to conventional cell
culture so how do organs on chips
compare
to standard 3d cell cultures and for
this question
if you'd be able to answer both for the
lung chips that you described today
and just on a larger note that we see in
other organs as well
yeah so and again another really
fantastic question
and we asked this question a lot and
um i for those people who know me well
know that i always boil it down to the
by bother question
um because yeah why bother with these
chips
and so let's just think primarily here
about viral infection because that's
been the main topic of of the
presentation
and cells and culture can be easily
infected by virus so i think there's
lots of data out there in viral cells
and mtck
cells or whose cells for instance where
the virus has actually
been shown to infect the cells very
easily
but what's not often apparent is that
um many of these cells so viral cells
for instance are actually
interferon deficient so to actually get
the viral infection and to start to
model
and the responses and in that cellular
system you actually have to add the
exogenous
interferon into the system to get the
cells to work in the right way
and you know for your experiment some
other cell types also lack things like
serine proteases so they have to be
added in an exogenous way and quite
frankly
and the the one of the the reasons why
um the cells and in the culture perhaps
have a disadvantage is that they sit in
a very static environment in other words
they're completely submerged
in media and they sit in that media for
24 48 sometimes even up to 96 hours so
again not really representing what you
would see in the body
on the flip side with the the chip and
where we see the advantage is that the
cells um have this dynamic fluid flow
which means that um in its simplest
terms it delivers nutrients
removes waste from the cells and this
increases their viability
but that also gives um shear stress
which is a key stimulus to the cells
and and together with that and the care
around the micro environment that we
take when we build the lung chip so
i showed for the alveolus that we
actually apply a stretch because that's
what these cells see
when they're inside the body those also
give the cells additional stimuli
and those all together what that means
is that the cells not only
are um happy they are um
viable for longer but they actually
function in a way that they would do um
in vivo so and from for me
there's a clear advantage in using the
chip and
i think the second part of your the
question was um whether we
see similar advantages in other organs
and
and one of the other organ chips it
really springs to mind for me
is the proximal tubule and so here
and one of the the main jobs as people
will probably appreciate of the proximal
tubule is around reabsorption
of um key nutrients prior to
um you know the excretion of the the
fluid from the body
and what we know is those many drug
transporters are present
on these epithelial cells and in a 2d
culture
and you can actually find the messenger
rna for these drug transporters
but because the cell is not polarized
correctly
the transporter doesn't set him either
in the apical or basolateral
membrane and as a consequence doesn't
function correctly
so when we apply our and our chip
technology we we can actually see the
correct polarization
of the proximal tubule epithelial cell
and as a consequence we can actually
look
um in great detail at drug transporter
activity
and now for for those people who
um are interested we have and we had a
poster
at the the virtual society of toxicology
meeting
and where we demonstrated um good
functional characterization of these
drug transporters in the chip
so different model and another example
of how
the the chip and the micro environment
is really important
to enable us to drive the right
functionality
thank you lorna so we just got the the
one minute notice here from go to
webinar
um so unfortunately that's all the time
we have for the live q a
i want to thank everyone for joining
today's session if you asked a question
and we were unable to answer
we're going to be following up with you
directly and if you have any additional
questions
or just want to learn more about the
lawn chip please email us
at info emulatebio.com
you can also check out our luncheon page
on the website and we're going to be
adding some more links there
including links to the publications
whose data was shared today
thank you and have a great day